allez allez les amis on parlait du
Festival de Cannes ça commence ce mardi
il y a beaucoup de choses à dire sur
Cannes vous voulez connaître tout sur
Cannes les indiscrétions la montée des
marches les soirées comment ça se passe
et bien on en parle tout de suite avec
nos deux invités
[Applaudissements]
les plus connues et admirer de la
planète
le Festival de Cannes est depuis sa
création en 1939 il y a 83 ans
l'événement people le plus prestigieux
au monde chaque printemps de Brad Pitt à
Leonardo DiCaprio en passant par Marion
Cotillard les plus grandes stars du
cinéma défilent sur la Croisette et la
petite ville devient le temps du
festival le centre du monde en marche du
festival et de sa mythique montée des
marches à l'image des cultissimes soirée
blanche des 10 Barclay d'énormes fêtes
démesurée sont organisées tout au long
de l'événement seulement voilà depuis
quelques années et l'essor des réseaux
sociaux le festival semble perdre un peu
en gamme aujourd'hui n'importe quel
starlette de télé ou des réseaux peut
s'y rendre chaque année pour nous parler
de l'évolution de cet événement hors
norme nous recevons le trémond d'un
Massimo Gargia et Christophe Leroy le
chef cuisinier le plus emblématique de
la Côte d'Azur alors selon vous le
Festival de Cannes est-il encore
l'événement people incontournable de
l'année
vous allez en 2020 chers amis nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir Massimo Gardia
bonsoir Massimo toujours un plaisir de
vous voir et le grand chef Christophe
Leroy bonsoir Christophe c'est en entend
cette musique c'est la montée des
marches une angoisse quand vous montez
les marches
on veut savoir toutes les indiscrétions
Massimo il est tout le temps vous êtes
tout le temps au Festival de Cannes vous
non
télé marche avec de superbes actrices
les festivals des cannes n'est pas
seulement la montée des marches c'est
une énorme marché bien sûr tout le monde
va vous vendre tout c'est vrai il y a
les bijoutiers qui va aller bijoux les
couturiers qui vont les robes ça c'est
du 16 au 27 mai à Cannes comme tous les
ans c'est à l'origine évidemment pour
récompenser les meilleurs films mes
meilleurs acteurs etc cette année c'est
Kara Mastroianni qui sera la maîtresse
de cérémonie mais aussi beaucoup de
stars internationales seront présentes
encore cette année sont attendus
Léonardo Dicaprio le dit il vient tous
les ans avec d'ailleurs avec sa petite
chérie
et Harrison Ford aussi parce que ils
vont présenter le dernier
dernier
saga de Indiana Jones avec Calista avec
qui avec Calista ça accompagne oui ah
oui c'est vrai vous avez raison oui tout
le monde sera là et Christophe Laura
vous on vous a annoncé comme le grand
manitou des soirées Saint-Tropez c'est
vrai j'en suis témoin
on va parler de ça avec vous mais en
tout cas pour revenir au final de Cannes
c'est de quand même le quatrième plus
gros événement médiatique de tout le
pays avec des retombées économiques tout
de même est important de le dire plus de
100 millions d'euros 10 fois plus que le
budget de fonctionnement mais au-delà
des films en compétition évidemment
quand c'est le rendez-vous qui fait
rêver tous les people je crois que c'est
on retrouve tout le monde Massimo vu que
tu connaissait la terre entière tous les
plus grands noms d'ailleurs tous les
grands noms du CAC 40 les stars les
mannequins tout le monde est là à Cannes
c'est incroyable phénomène unique dans
le monde parce avant n'était pas comme
ça avant c'était un phénomène culturel
oui les cinémas les gens qui sont que le
cinéma
quelque chose unique qui s'appelle que
les autres festivals Festival de Venise
Berlin ne sont pas comme ça
qu'il n'y a pas de festival les plus
grands succès c'est le Festival de
Cannes parce que les gens vont pour
d'autres raisons comme je vous ai dit
ils vont il va déjà qui n'ont rien à
faire avec les cinémas oui d'ailleurs ça
se voit poser des questions
qui n'ont jamais travaillé ils n'ont
jamais fait c'est plus c'est la festival
des cinémas c'est pas un festival de
cinéma c'est foire de la vanité
des choses comme on dit pour vendre
c'est joli le festival du cinéma
ça va amuser mais voyez on voit quelques
photos il y a quand même la mandalières
avec vous d'ailleurs avec vous Massimo
non mais ça c'est le monde entier
en scène je suis pas malheureusement
j'ai pas fait beaucoup de films je vais
dire j'ai honte de marcher les monter
les marches je ne comprends pas il y a
des gens qui n'ont rien à faire avec qui
montrent qu'est-ce que vous allez vendre
là-bas tout le monde vend des trucs
je suis
payé pour être représentent dans les
soirées des amis milliardaires
américains parce que il faut dire mon
cher Massimo qu'effectivement il faut
payer d'abord pour monter les marches
demande de l'argent c'est payant de
monter les marques
ou par le joaillier qu'on connaît bien
etc non mais en général les gens lambda
s'ils sont pas invités par la mairie de
Cannes ou par le Festival de Cannes ils
peuvent monter les marches mais en
payant et c'est très cher
les marchés noirs des billets oui on
peut tout acheter quand même si on a de
l'argent même maladie après l'ouverture
on achète
l'époque que j'ai travaillé pour des
Grisons les plus belles fêtes et Chopard
il y avait des gens qui payaient pour
une place 20 000 euros 25000 euros mais
oui vous rendez compte que ce fameux
joyau qui pouvait décider il y a aussi
Elton John qui est là qui fait un
concert privé il y a aussi tout ça c'est
tout un grand truc à l'Eden Rock aussi
chacun fait ses grands dîner qui coûte
très cher Christophe Leroy vous ça
m'intéresse aussi parce pour vous pour
ceux qui vous connaissent pas vous avez
déjà plus connus de la Jet 7 il faut
quand même le dire les stars françaises
internationales votre livre qui est là
mille et une vie d'un chef voilà si vous
voulez tout savoir dans les truffés on a
un petit extrait de vos fameuses soirées
blanches auxquelles j'ai participé il
faut quand même le dire
du champagne qui coule à flot et des
jolies filles c'est le casting parfait
pour une soirée idéale sur la rivière à
française plus de 700 invités sont déjà
arrivés mais Christophe Leroy n'en finit
plus de régler les derniers détails tu
vois ça c'est un nouveau truc qu'on a
fait et je voudrais que toutes les
filles de façon sexy moi je les sucettes
en faut des photos les actrices tout ça
tu vois
[Applaudissements]
la musique de ce soir à l'image de la
fête
la convivialité je crois que tout ce que
je voulais mais t'inquants sont
[Applaudissements]
parmi des chefs pour faire la cuisine
j'étais ébloui de voir tout ça la vie a
fait que j'ai démarré mon métier de chef
à Saint-Tropez en commençant sur le
match de Johnny et justement c'est
Johnny il fait beaucoup pour vous voilà
le 7 juillet 90 et après c'était au
château la Messardière
et puis elle dit qu'il est devenu mon
meilleur supporter et à la fois mon
meilleur ambassadeur et qui m'a
invité à cuisiner chez lui pendant
quelques années puis la vie a fait que
il avait pu sa maison et un jour je lui
ai dit j'aimerais faire une fête en
votre honneur et mais il y a une
condition tout le monde soit en blanc et
c'est là que j'ai repris à la fin de la
soirée mais c'était parfait et chaque
année j'ai continué pendant 20 ans
[Rires]
toutes ces belles propriétés et les
yachts et ma spécialité c'est de faire
des fêtes dans les maisons et sur les
bateaux et c'était une opportunité pour
moi de montrer de mon savoir-faire et de
réunir tous ces gens une fois par an de
juillet
je pourrais faire une fête en fait c'est
juste
que je déteste
tranquille
Christophe quand on reçoit comme ça
toutes ces stars internationales il y a
certaines exigences sûrement
racontez-nous des petits secrets qui
veut quoi et comment des trucs insolites
sans doute vous voyez plein de choses
déjà le la liste des invités très
importante il faut et j'ai appris ça
avec Eddy Barclay le mélange des genres
et des gens il faut plein de gens
d'horizons différents et moi mon métier
de cuisinier je l'ai fait tellement être
passion que cette alchimie faisait que
début juillet il y a cette ce côté la
chaleur le beau temps il y a toujours le
dernier amour de l'été Massimo
d'ailleurs que j'ai croisé pendant 25
ans pour les dîner que j'ai servi il m'a
aidé il y a des fois il m'a amené ivana
Trump qui a été la marraine de la soirée
blanche pas mélodie et aussi
l'anniversaire d'Ivana Trump tout à fait
son anniversaire parce qu'il va
malheureusement que décédé c'est une
femme extraordinaire mais comme tous les
gens qui ont beaucoup d'argent et
l'aimer aussi les cadeaux les dîners
gratuites
et Christophe
il était toujours très généreux a
toujours fait des dîners on dîner pour
100 personnes quand même c'est beaucoup
le truc le plus dingue qu'on vous ai
demandé de faire Christophe le plus
dingue il a eu ce pique-nique avec
Johnny aussi tout à fait
le lendemain le lendemain
j'ai quelques vies et soirée
Saint-Bernard non mais j'adore c'était
fantastique
lendemain d'une soirée blanche chez Eddy
où il y avait Barbara Streisand Johnson
tu peux tu peux faire ton plus je
demande quel jour je peux faire le ping
dis le lendemain je t'emmènerai quelques
invités et il m'a emmené 400 personnes
sur la plage il faisait une chaleur pas
possible et c'était l'organisation était
pas parti
c'était pour quitter le bateau de Johnny
franchement on est d'accord hein
c'était exceptionnel on a vécu de très
grands moments la cuisine est
exceptionnelle lui adorable les invités
de qualité c'était top franchement
c'était payant vous retrouvez non enfin
si Johnny y commandait et c'est ça comme
aussi c'est la comme à l'époque c'était
à l'époque c'était grandiose Aznavour
Barbara
aujourd'hui
où vous continuez vous à aller Massimo
je crois où vous êtes toujours un peu
dans la Jet 7 etc qu'est-ce que vous
pensez toutes les filles de téléréalité
en fait c'est vous qui avez vécu les
grandes heures du glamour de Cannes et
on va dire les plus grand
es vous êtes un personnage
maintenant vous êtes un personnage à
vous tous seuls j'aime bien ça chez vous
parce que vous balancez aussi sur tout
le monde et ça c'est assez drôle mais
qu'est-ce que c'est maintenant pour vous
aussi
c'est vrai que la raison il n'y a plus
les grands stars d'une époque vraiment
très important il y a tout des gens qui
m'a aussi Saint-Tropez ou si vous parlez
de Saint-Tropez il y a encore et un peu
là aussi les gens vont pour aussi pour
faire des carrières pour connaître des
gens c'est tout au marché là-bas aussi
ça a marché aussi c'est ça et vous avez
raison Massimo de le dire ça il fait ça
pas comme il y a tous les gens du CAC 40
tous les grands patrons d'industrie tout
ça qui sont là-bas quand vous les
croisez vous les rencontrer
effectivement ça peut faciliter les
choses Florian oui moi je j'ai une autre
question pour Massimo est-ce que c'est
vrai que j'ai découvert le Festival de
Cannes dans les années 2000-2010 et
c'était encore les belles années du du
côté grandes fêtes à ciel ouvert où il y
avait des fêtes partout sur les bateaux
dans les hôtels etc aujourd'hui moi je
trouve pense que c'est un peu la fête
des annonceurs c'est à dire que le
business a pris un peu le pouvoir à
Cannes il y a plus cette même
insouciance la folie qui avait et je
pense que c'est aussi peut-être par
rapport au star américaine en tout cas à
l'émergence du portable et des photos où
il y a plus dans les soirées dans tous
ces endroits cette petite folie ce côté
très pétillant qui avait ce que vous
lavez ressenti dans les dans la dans les
deux dernières parce que les temps ça
change les intérêts ça change
naturellement c'est pas les mêmes
groupes de gens qui vont c'est vrai et
c'est un coup de projecteur
international attendez qui a monté les
marches ici
par les chaînes quand j'étais chef du
service média du Figaro forcément tu es
invités
non
mais c'est vrai qu'on les voit après
quand il y a pas de tapis rouge ça fait
tout bizarre parce que les petites
marches ridicules mais moi je les ai
monté à l'époque où il y avait encore
les hots d'or les stars du x qui étaient
là
de Cannes c'était les plus belles
soirées et tout le monde ou soirée
d'humilité la montée des marches parce
que quand vous êtes bon ben des acteurs
connus et reconnus moi je l'ai fait
chaque année la montée de marche depuis
les années 80 puisque la VSD je pourrais
ça aussi oui 1880
mais ce qui était incroyable c'est que
les photographes qui hurlent qui hurlent
partout tout le temps vous connaissez ça
ils disent qui sait qui
photographies photographier
en tant qu'invité aussi après la
médaille de Lila meurt en 94 parce
qu'effectivement j'étais un nom qui
faisait parler voilà est-ce que la
question c'est est-ce que c'était mieux
avant moi je pense que oui
non mais je pense que tout le monde
partage cet avis même pour les Jeux
Olympiques aujourd'hui vous me posez la
question moi j'ai préféré les Olympiades
avant 2000 que celle de maintenant qui
sont devenus extra business que business
restant sur Cannes parce que Cannes
c'est aussi du business oui c'est une
vitrine formidable c'est pour ça que les
grands joaillers sont là que les grands
mannequins sont là les grandes marques
de cosmétiques sont là et heureusement
parce que ça aide à faire vivre aussi le
Festival de Cannes parce que tous ces
gens-là qui viennent toutes les stars
qui viennent aussi souvent les stars ne
viennent pas pour un film elles viennent
pour une marque etc et donc ça enrichit
le festival
ont payé tous les saints ma main pour
les robes pour porter aussi bien sûr on
perd des chaussures et son pays c'est
son pays c'est qui gagne le plus sont
les grands stars ouais bien sûr les
chiffres colossals et parlons pas de
l'enfer la grande soirée au profit de la
lutte contre le sida il y a trois
classes de billets les 13000 les billets
que vous êtes derrière à côté des
toilettes
les 25000 au milieu et pour être à côté
de la scène c'est 35000 je sais c'est
fini l'histoire des Américaines sont
énormes pour une soirée
il y a 15 jours à peine
du monde
qui me propose et demanda oui je pensais
que tu es gentil c'est ce que tu viens
de moi ma vie s'il vous propose la
gentillesse et vous vous êtes parmi les
personnes qui ont la possibilité
d'acheter une place et tu sais combien
c'était la place
de 5000 dollars oh là là là allez
j'étais très flatté parce que j'ai pensé
que encore j'ai la réputation en
Amérique elle était milliardaire
c'est pas pour nous ça Christophe vous
avez fait des dîners aussi coûteux que
ça oui bien sûr ah oui j'ai fait des
belles choses
je sais mais
c'est vrai que Saint-Tropez la Côte
d'Azur il y a des maisons des mesures
des bateaux et comme c'est mon métier
tous les jours pendant 100 jours par an
on fait des choses vous êtes toujours
d'ailleurs à Saint-Tropez
cette année j'ai fait des belles fêtes
tous l'été
ça vous dirait vous d'y aller et Déborah
je vous vois bien je suis allée l'été
dernier c'était très sympa je suis
restée quatre jours je me suis endettée
pour 6 ans mais c'est super sympa j'ai
bien rigolé allez ça coûte
aussi avec
Isaac il y a longtemps
plastique
en fait le problème c'est que quand je
faisais les émissions de cinéma sur
Paris Première j'étais jamais envoyé
spécial moi je restais toujours à Paris
j'ai jamais monté les marches moi je
peux vous donner à quoi monter une
marche pour moins cher que ça si vous
voulez
vous rendez pas compte
une émotion de de monter les marches
mais est-ce que les gens vont voir les
films voilà c'est ça parce que vous
savez quoi
et ce bar c'est le côté latérale je l'ai
fait je dois reconnaître je l'ai fait
une fois comment me dire j'arrive en
haut des marches et on me dit j'étais je
dis pas avec qui j'étais parce que vous
allez dire que voilà et en montant on me
dit non Isabelle Adjani ah et et
ouais et en même temps le film vous
allez vous emmerder ça dure deux heures
Isabelle dit non moi je vais voir le
film je veux voir le film Ben et non
alors du coup moi je me suis taillé sur
le côté
chers amis Christophe Leroy mille et une
vie d'un chef des mythiques soirée
blanche de Saint-Tropez au dîner
clandestin d'ailleurs
tout est là si vous posez 1000 questions
tout est là les amis mon cher Massimo
Garcia c'est toujours un plaisir vous
allez y aller à Cannes alors on va vous
voir là-bas cette année
c'est pas moi qui ai acheté les très
bien merci beaucoup Massimo merci trésor
merci les amis merci à vous cherchez à
cœur j'espère que vous avez passé une
très bonne soirée avec nous
[Applaudissements]